يعني هي ليست تعقيدات هي
تجليات جماليه تنوع وغنى بالحرف
وهذا الغنى له عده اسباب يعني احد الاسباب
انتقال الحرف من حاضره الى حاضره يعني
لنقل القاهره هي اوجدت او كرست انواع الخط
الكوفي فخرج عنا الكوفي المملوكي والكوفي
الفاطمه بمعنى انه الحرف هو صوره
وارتساب
لفتره معينه وهو شكلها البصري
بدمشق اوجد النسخ واوجدت خطوط اخرى في
بغداد وجدت خط الثلث ونسب الى الدائره في
الفتره العثمانيه اوجدوا عده خطوط الرقعه
والديواني واخر وفي بلاد فارس ووجدوا خط
التعليق فاذا كل بيئه
افرزت نوع خط يشبعها
لما جاء الخط الى المغرب العربي ايضا
افرزت خطوط اخرى ملفتك انه في دمشق ونسخ
الاساس طبيعي يعني هو بلش في عند العقبه
الامويه اظن يعني تبلور بالحقبه الامويه
يعني ارادوا ان يعني ان الناس تقرا في
جميعا يعني تخيل انه من الحرف عندما تقرا
مخطوط تعرف انه هذا الحرف جاء من نيسابور
من هذه المنطقه من هذه الفتره هذا لا يوجد
باي لغه اخرى لانه فن لكن ارجع لسؤالك
الاول الاول وهو لماذا الخط معقد ولا يقرا
ولا يقرا ولكن لا يقرا عند الجميع طيب
الجواب هو عندما ترى اي تلتقي باي اوروبي
الان هو قادر ان يستمتع باللوحه التجريديه
والحتى اللوحه المفاهيميه واللوحه الاخرى
عنده وعي بصري وعنده تكوين تربوي واضح
بالعالم العربي لا يوجد هذا الشيء يعني
انا مره حضرت لقاء لاحد الممثلين الكبار
يعني سؤال سالوه عدد ثلاثه انواع الخطوط
العربي الخط العربي لم يتمكن يعني
جهد ممكن صفحتين يقراها الفرد ممكن تساهم
بانه تنوروا شوي عن هذا الفن فهذه المساله
تربويه وحتى شخصيه احيانا التقي باوروبا
يعرف الخط الكوفي من المسند من الريحان في
خط اسمه الريحان جميل
فهذا التقصير وليس يعني نعم لا تطلب اي
تقصير لوحه بالتعليم بالمناهج يعني لا
تطلب من اي احد يعرف لوحه سلفادور داليا
او يفهم لا هو الخط يعني لانه هو ينقل نص
الخط بينقل لك نص طيب وهذا النص له معنى
وهذا المعنى يطمح بشيء يعني يطمح للوصول
الى شيء معين يعني المفروض يقولون الناس
صح انا هذا هو جوهر سوداني قديما كان الكل
يقرا هذا
لاجل ذلك اتى النسخ وتعودت عليه تعود علي
البصر هاي القيمه الوظيفيه للحرف نعم
لماذا اخترع خط الرقعه لسهوله الكتابه صح
هذا المقصود بو ضوح الكتابه والنسخ اخذ
الخط الرسمي المقروء اما الفن فشيء اخر